so observation
you start here your partner's the
opposite side of you you move you cap to
their head or you cut to the wrist
and it comes to an end
okay so the first part of the practice
we do we we cut a to the rest
or we come to the Head
to the side of the head
then you'll come in this cat is still
the same I don't I don't handle it I
just
move my body to a different angle so my
cuts are straight
but if I move to the side
some teachers they they bring off the
side of the head and they cut like this
to me this is the incorrect
of noticing my sensitive teachers so
here
is straight part of the practice capture
the wrist
so
they come to the West
or
he cut to the Head the temple
so this is the observation part now
today I'll put my back out on and it's
for purpose the purpose is by the time
you've arrived at Showdown your first
background you should have been serious
enough to want to study more in depth
the alcoholic you know and not just
think that um you're somebody from one
of those Marvel films that you know you
know you're somebody
you know a comic strip of a super person
with super powers okay you should have
perhaps enjoyed those egotistic moments
and many people they never lose it it
don't matter how many downgrades they
get
but the observation that I've seen and I
want you to observe others
as well as yourself doing this because
by the time you get a black belt you
should have learned the word zanjin
zanshin doesn't mean just fanatical
awareness but it means awareness
you look up down out so even though I'm
looking at a camera I'm saying we're
still good over here I'm saying that the
items on the Shelf over there the grass
outside because the doors open
I'm saying some plants moving the wind
outside behind the camera so I'm
observing all this this is ancient
awareness
perhaps you'll hear sounds as well
sanction
and why is it observed when I'm watching
a partner practices so downgrades of all
levels
is this
we'll start with the first part of the
practice
hey
that looked all okay I took my zanji if
you are prepared myself I calmed down
and stayed there
some people
have bad sand Shin he's in a hurry to
just do them like a sausage fraction
again
they
said as he would say this is zero plus
zero in other words it's worthless
it adds up to nothing
so your Zan chin your awareness
is to be aware of everything but in a
calm State and a calm state
hey
then I watch this
I'll do it for a different manual
deal with your partner you're both
focused
they they cut you cut to their list
hey
through the head
have you noticed anything
importantly noticed
have you been on tonight observing
hey
have you been observing
for the moment you're into the dojo
well and now that eventually outside as
well in the in every daily life daily
life
but if you were observing
I had my lamb chin when I started it's
like I switched I switched it on I'd
done the car I kept this engine
calm down wasn't a rush to get back but
then what did I do
I've done this and I casually sort of
went back to at the start and then
this is like the worst thing
that you'll ever see
perhaps for beginners after going about
half of the into blue yes you know
second queue I would tell them off
but I'm not expecting them to have his
answer but round about second kill I'm
expecting it becomes serious about the
Arts
and if they're not observing themselves
and seeing that this must not happen
then
it destroys the me the whole point of
the part of the practice the partner
practice starts when you bow to each
other
but when you pick up your Ken and walk
towards the other person really it must
start when you bow to each other
you draw your swords to each other
please start the cut momentarily after
you step out
you then lift the cane and you watch
them as they walk back to the spot and
you walk back in the spot
if you can see in the camera I've turned
my Ken slightly
I don't keep it stiff like this except I
keep it stiff like this I felt a little
bit what I call wooden I feel a little
bit like a robot
by doing it just a little twist so
there's a little secret I'm giving you
here don't twist it tends to soften me
but only and enough that I can react
very fast okay you stay stiff it's
difficult to react fast
and without it being like in jerk type
movements
so
you have your partner
give me a clear eyes on your partner I
always look in this area around the
chest
keep your eyes on your partner
take out the can
five centimeters between the Academy of
head minimum so they don't tap
okay you can't
keep your eyes
you soften this little bit
when you walk back
hey if it's here to the head you just
allow a little bit
to walk back so always keeping it in
line with the sternum where you're going
to start
so
I'm here
I can't even if it's to the Head
I'm gonna keep watching them
the feeling is I'm extending
even though I'm not showing up I'm
extending through my head my thoughts
projecting my head
and I straighten it up
hey
I lift it up soften it soften it
pull it back
Australian mechanic back
finish you've been out looking at kind
of them not that floor
and then you finish
okay this is to make this a very
important observation and I hope it
helps you in your development thank you